Quindi cos'è Qiskit?
Qiskit è un kit di sviluppo software open source
per lavorare con i computer quantistici
a livello di circuit
algoritmi e moduli applicativi. Questo SDK
permette a chiunque di programmare su veri computer quantistici dal
proprio laptop. In due righe di codice puoi accedere
a diversi sistemi quantistici, dai superconduttori
agli ioni intrappolati qubit. Vuoi emulare il comportamento di un computer quantistico?
Cambia semplicemente una riga di codice
e simula i tuoi quantum circuit sul nostro simulatore ad alte prestazioni.
Qiskit è uno strumento usato da decine di
migliaia di persone in tutto il mondo che cercano di
costruire il futuro. Che tu sia ricercatore, sviluppatore
o stia semplicemente cercando di iniziare,
Qiskit offre una serie di
funzionalità disponibili per le tue esigenze,
permettendo a chiunque di fare cose
come costruire il tuo primo quantum circuit,
eseguire algoritmi quantistici cross-domain
e studiare fenomeni quantistici fondamentali.
Forse questo è il momento perfetto per coinvolgerti in prima persona
e trovare tutti gli strumenti di cui hai bisogno,
inclusi veri computer quantistici
e l'SDK attraverso Qiskit,
e una community felice di darti il benvenuto
e rispondere a qualsiasi domanda tu possa avere lungo il percorso.
Puoi iniziare oggi stesso
su Qiskit.